you're a child of God you got purpose
and it all put it there and nobody can
take it away these books are for white
folks they're full of things yokan
wouldn't understand
you're special born Nathaniel study hard
here your slaves sure to know how to
behave
now they God fear one of the preachers
people might pay good money to have him
calm down a bit especially about one of
their own lead you to Peter 2:18 submit
yourselves to your masters not only to
those who are good and consider it but
also to those or harsh
what you think you're doing boy
I asked you a question you don't preach
across the wall learned your lesson oh
yes to watch a strongman broken down
it's a terrible thing Lord spoken to me
visions of what's to come
now rise of good against evil are we
going to go five once it begins our
brothers and sisters are John and we're
number in the hundreds thousands
I pray you sing a new song
but the high plains of God filled the
mouths of the saints and a two-edged
sword in their hand to execute vengeance
on the demonic nations
we need something waiting on us we were
and blood at the Rouge you listen to him
and you might just make it into heaven
hey man black Bob